هناك راكب أمواج مبتدئ قبالة ساحل
سان دييغو، وقد منحه جميع راكبي الأمواج من البشر
ختم الموافقة،
لحظة من السعادة الخالصة بالنسبة لي،
وأفسحت جيني كيم بكل سرور مكانًا لجرو فقمة الميناء هذا
على لوح التزلج الخاص بها يومًا بعد يوم، حيث
ظهر في  شاطئ المحيط الهادئ
والتسكع مع أولئك الذين عادةً ما يعلقون عشرة،
حتى خبراء البحرية مثل
جيني سميث من Sea World كانوا في حيرة من أمرهم
لسبب غريب كان القفز من لوح ركوب الأمواج إلى لوح
ركوب الأمواج إلى لوح ركوب الأمواج بالتأكيد ليست أختام الميناء
العادية عادة ما تكون
في مأزق ولكن هذا كان
ودودًا للغاية يتسلق البرد على متن السفينة  يتدحرج
بدلاً من أن يكون معاديًا للمجتمع، كان
متزامنًا مع ركوب الأمواج مع التخلي عن
راكبي الأمواج، أطلق عليه اسم سامي على اسم
كتاب الأطفال سامي الختم، الرجل
الذي أطلق لقطات الطائرة بدون طيار، وجد إد هارتل
الختم ملهمًا في زمن
الظلام، لقد كان هذا
رن هاتف Sea World San Diego الخفيف
مع مكالمات حول Sammy، قام
فريق الإنقاذ بفحصه ووجده
بصحة جيدة، لماذا ينجذب إلى
ألواح ركوب الأمواج، كانت غريزتي الأولى هي أن
أسماك القرش في الماء
قتلت أسماك القرش الفقمات وأسود البحر في هذا  الشاطئ
ولكن جيني تقول أن سامي بدا هادئًا
وغير خائف، وكان وجهه قريبًا جدًا
منه كما لو كان سيقبلني كما لو كان
مختومًا ليس بقبلة بل بشم
نشرته على Instagram ولم تتخلص أبدًا من
هذا المنتدى، مثل هذه اللحظة السحرية من
الاتصال بـ  الطبيعة عندما
قال Beach Boys إن كل
من يعرف الجميع سيشمل سامي
السيليمو سي إن إن نيويورك